You've now heard three debates, months of campaigning and way too many TV commercials.
And now you've got a choice.
Over the last four years, we've made real progress digging our way out of policies that...
...gave us two prolonged wars, record deficits and the worst economic crisis since the Great Depression.
And Governor Romney wants to take us back to those policies.
A foreign policy that's wrong and reckless.
Economic policies that won't create jobs, won't reduce our deficit,...
...but will make sure that folks at the very top don't have to play by the same rules that you do.
I've got a different vision for America.
I want to build on our strengths.
And I've put forward a plan to make sure that we're bringing manufacturing jobs back to our shores...
...by rewarding companies and small businesses that are investing here, not overseas.
I want to make sure we've got the best education system in the world.
And we're retaining our workers for the jobs of tomorrow.
I want to control our own energy by developing oil and natural gas...
...but also the energy sources of the future.
Yes, I want to reduce our deficit by cutting spending that we don't need...
...but also by asking the wealthy to do a little bit more...
...so that we can invest in things like research and technology...
...that are the key to a 21st century economy.
As Commander in Chief, I will maintain the strongest military in the world,...
...keep faith with our troops and go after those who would do us harm.
But after a decade of war,...
...I think we all recognize we've got to do some nation building here at home:...
...rebuilding our roads, our bridges,...
...and especially caring for our veterans who sacrificed so much for our freedom.
And we've been through tough times,...
....but we always bounce back because of our character,...
...because we pull together.
And if I have the privilege of being your president for another four years,...
...I promise you I will always listen to your voices.
I will fight for your families.
And I will work every single day...
...to make sure that America continues to be the greatest nation on Earth.
Thank you.